Do you know that moment when someone
tells you your history is a gift? That
your ancestors suffering was actually
good for you and you can't find the
words to respond. It's not just
insulting. It's the same lie that
justifies why 46 of 49 protesters were
killed in indigenous regions of Peru in
2022 and 2023.
I'll show you exactly how a 500-year-old
Spanish lie connects directly to bullets
fired in my wife's hometown with
receipts from over 40 academic sources.
My wife's from Hulyaka, Peru. She is
indigenous. I live with her in
Nayakucha. Last year in Lima, a Spanish
Airbnb owner told us that she should be
grateful for colonization, that Spain
brought civilization, freed her people
from oppression, gave them rights. I
froze. I knew it was wrong, but I didn't
have the evidence to prove it. Millions
believe this. In Peru, people tell my
wife she's Meazza,
improving her race by being with me. But
there's something about these claims
that most people get completely
backward. The Spanish said they brought
civilization to cannibals and savages.
Your first instinct might be to argue
the Incas weren't cannibals, but that's
the wrong approach. The real question is
why Spanish reports suddenly started
calling everyone cannibals. After 1503,
Columbus created the word cannibal by
conflating Caribbean peoples called Kiba
with eating human flesh based more on
imagination than observation.
But why? Because in 1503, Apool said you
could legally enslave one specific
group, cannibals.
Suddenly, every group that resisted
became cannibals in Spanish reports. It
wasn't anthropology. It was a business
model. For Peru, the Incas explicitly
shunned eating human flesh.
Archaeological digs found, and I quote,
nothing approaching the thousands of
victims the Spanish claimed. But here's
what the Spanish actually found.
Philippiguan Pomayala
Ketwa Nobleman spent 15 years
documenting what he saw. 1,189
pages, 398
handdrawn illustrations showing Spanish
officials beating indigenous women,
workers driven to mines, and priests
demanding sexual favors. The Incas were
sophisticated. They governed 9 million
people, built 5,000 kilometers of road
networks that some Spanish chronicers
admitted were finer than ancient Rome.
They created earthquake proof
architecture without mortar. The Indian
peoples had three fundamental
principles. Amasua don't steal, amalula,
don't lie, and amakila, don't be lazy.
The Spanish violated all three. They
stole 24 tons of gold from Atawalpa
alone. They lied about providing
protection and they forced indigenous
people into brutal labor while
extracting wealth. The Spanish didn't
bring civilization, they destroyed it.
The Spanish destroyed the most
sophisticated civilization in South
America. They turned those exact regions
into extraction zones. 500 years later,
those same regions are still being
targeted. That's not coincidence. That's
continuity. But maybe you're thinking
the Incas were not angels. They had
forced labor, too. Doesn't that make the
Spanish liberation partially through?
This is where it gets dark. November
1532.
Pizarro's trap closes. Atawalpa is
captured. He offers his tour's richest
ransom. He would fill a room 24 ft long,
18 ft wide, and 8 ft high with gold. He
delivers 24 tons of gold and silver. The
Spanish take it, and then they put him
on trial for treason against Spain, a
country he had never been to. July 26th,
1533, they execute him. But that was
just the beginning. The Spanish took the
incamita, rotational community labor,
where the state fed you, and they turned
it into this. Potosi, a Spanish frier,
called it a mouth of hell. 13,500
men forced annually to work at altitude,
underground,
50° heat, 300 lb loads. Conservative
scholars estimate over 1 million dead at
Possi alone. Mercury poisoning killed a
third of workers. Highland provinces
lost 60% of their population. When
Tupekamaru II rebelled against this
system in 1780, Spain killed up to
100,000 indigenous people. But
indigenous people never stopped
resisting. Peru went from 9 million
people to 600,000
in one century. 90% dead. That's not
liberation. That's the worst demographic
disaster in human history. The Spanish
love citing their protective laws like
the new laws of 1542.
But here's what they don't tell you.
When Vestroy Blasco Nunes Vela arrived
to enforce them, the Spanish colonists
beheaded him, the king revoked the laws.
But let's say you believe Spain tried.
When did indigenous Peruvians actually
receive rights? Peru gained independence
in 1821.
Forced labor ended 148 years later.
Ketwa recognized as an official language
154 years after independence and the
right to be consulted about mining on
their land
years after independence.
Today, an indigenous Peruvian needs 80%
more job applications for the same
interview. Life expectancy is 20 years
lower. December 2022, Pedro Castillo,
Peru's first rural provincial president,
gets removed from office. Protests
erupt. January 9th, 2023. Hulyaka, my
wife's hometown. 18 people are killed in
one day. In total, 49 people end up
dead, 39 shot. The police confiscated
zero firearms from protesters. Human
Rights Watch found no protest with guns
in 37 hours of footage. The new
president Bolyarte's response. Puno is
not Peru. So why do Spanish people and
Peruvian elites still believe these
lies? Spanish intellectuals created the
white legend claiming their colonization
was uniquely benevolent. Spain was
stigmatized in Europe for mixing with
Moors and Jews. When they mixed with
indigenous peoples, it confirmed
European prejudices about Spanish racial
impurity.
So they created Mistake. We're all mixed
as defense and hierarchy simultaneously.
And Spain still defends this today. In
2019,
Mexico's president asked Spain to
apologize for colonial abuses.
Spain's response, "The arrival of
Spaniards cannot be judged in the light
of contemporary considerations."
In other words, genocide can't be judged
by today's moral standards. That's
Spain's official position. Spain still
celebrates October the 12th as day of
espanidat celebrating the beginning of
colonization.
But let's be clear about how this mixing
actually happened. Most of this mixing
in the first century of colonization
happened through rape. Indigenous women
had no choice. Spanish men claimed right
of conquest over women's bodies just
like they claimed the land. Today they
package this violence as we're all
beautifully mixed. They tell my wife
she's improving her race, as if the
original mixing was voluntary, as if it
wasn't trauma passed down through
generations. They turned evidence of
rape into a national identity, then told
the descendants to be grateful. They're
rebranding sexual violence as progress,
just like they rebranded extraction as
development. and genocide as
civilization.
Scholar Marisol de Laadena documented
how it works. You improve your race by
accumulating money, going to expensive
university, moving neighborhoods,
forgetting where you come from.
Indigenous people must commit
deindianization to escape
discrimination. And here's how the lie
reproduces itself. A Colombian friend
went to a Catholic school founded
in6004.
Four centuries later, they're still
teaching that Columbus brought
civilization.
No mention of genocide, no mention of
slavery, no mention of rape. The schools
themselves are colonial infrastructure
still functioning, still lying. That's
not education. That's indoctrination
that's been running for 400 years.
Peruvian sociologist Analiano called
this coloniality
colonial structure surviving after
colonialism ends. Colonial power doesn't
die. It survives. It adapts. A 2021
economic history study proved former
Mita districts still have worse outcomes
400 years later. They are the poorest
regions today. The same regions where
protesters died in 2022,
where 75% of victims in Peru's 1980 to
2000 conflict were Ketwa speakers. The
extraction never stopped. It just
changed management. In 2024,
archaeologists scanned 179,000
kilometers of the Andes using satellite
AI. 95% of grit cells show no
archaeological traces. Where indigenous
communities once thrived, now just
emptiness, that emptiness is colonial
disruption visible from space. The
Spanish brought three things to Peru.
Death for 90% of the population,
extraction that continues today, and
lies about both. And these lies aren't
unique to Peru. The same schools, the
same improvement through rape rebranded
as mixing. The same violence against
those who resist are taught in Bgotaa,
Mexico City, and Santiago. 500 years of
resistance from Atawalpa to Tupakamaru
to the protesters in 2023.
the same fight, the same regions, the
same refusal to accept the lie.
Share this with anyone who thinks
colonization was civilizing. The sources
are below. And if you want more
evidence-based takedowns of historical
propaganda, subscribe. History versus
hype. Evidence beats mythology every
single time.